Wednesday is a fun day during football
season because we're caught between one
week and another week and you never
really know do you look back do you look
forward what do you do on Wednesday well
sometimes on Tuesday something falls
into your lap that requires your
attention on Wednesday and Chris this
one is a first for me
handshake gate the rant from Richard
Sherman the 49ers cornerback right after
the Monday night win over the Cleveland
Browns to michael silver of NFL media
who has an existing bias against Baker
Mayfield based upon his relationship
with former Browns coach Hugh Jackson
clear it's undeniable and I don't think
anybody's trying to push back against
that but Sherman went over the top with
his complaints about Mayfield snubbing
Sherman and DeForest Buckner another
49ers captain before the coin toss and
the way it was set up the way it was
characterized in the story it was clear
that Sherman was taking the position
that Baker Mayfield did not shake his
hand before the coin toss and that was
baked in all morning long
this idea that Mayfield was acting like
a punk and going out there and not
shaking the hands of a member of the NFL
Brotherhood and I was critical of him I
was like look you can't do that
this is not college this is not high
school you have to behave a certain way
and of all people Mayfield should know
that because he got snubbed at a game
between Oklahoma and Kansas and he was
upset the rest of the day because he got
snubbed when it was time to go out for
the coin toss and shake hands so by noon
or there abouts I caught wind of video
evidence Chris suggesting that there had
been a handshake now it took some time
to get the smoking gun there's the
smoking gun if you're watching
that's as smoking as it can get there's
a handshake and and you know the story
shifted it's funny Chris because
initially the evidence that came out was
inconclusive and Richard Sherman seized
on that with a screen shot saying he
didn't shake my hand
he didn't shake my hand well those
tweets have now since been deleted once
the conclusive evidence came out and I'm
left to wonder what in the hell is going
on here that Richard Sherman would have
that so wrong did he misperceive it did
he choose to
okay - not realizing there are cameras
everywhere or in your in midfield of an
NFL game before kickoff I can't
understand this and then I throw in the
NFL wrinkle dad access to all those
videos they have in-house video they
have NFL Films video you can check and
look at the video before you run with
this major story about how Richard
Sherman was snubbed by Baker Mayfield
I'm stunned by this I'm me too I mean on
so many levels I mean okay so first off
I understand people being a little
jealous mad whatever it may be about
Baker Mayfield I mean he is getting
treated like he's a superstar and has
not earned you know let's say is you
know per se there's his stripes yet as
far as the NFL is concerned and there
used to be an NFL culture of where you
know quarterbacks didn't do commercials
and things like that until you won a
Super Bowl or won a certain number of
games to establish yourself as that you
know NFL elite type quarterback and I'm
sure it rubs some people the wrong the
wrong way when they see Baker Mayfield
on national commercials and things like
that and they go gosh you know he
doesn't how many games is he won to this
point in his career what is it eleven
twelve I mean somewhere in that range so
I understand all of that but what I
don't get first off from that video we
just showed there obviously shook his
hands - if you want to really get into
like who really blue who off here Baker
may feel that gives everybody the hug
and the handshake dab Richard Sherman
won't even look him in the eye so I mean
if we're gonna start the disrespect
conversation it starts with Richard
Sherman let alone the hypocrisy of
Richard Sherman is absolutely astounding
you mean the guy back in 2012 on the
team that hadn't done crap to that point
who followed the legend of football Tom
Brady off the field with you mad bro is
now gonna teach us about respect on the
field are you freaking kidding me
and then to lie about it because it
looks like Richard wanted attention or
something I don't know and it's a bunch
of BS that's all I can say to this point
yeah and it really was a perfect storm
of events Chris because Mike silver was
the right guy to bring this to because
he's gonna look for anything to
criticize Baker Mayfield that's proven
now and I think if I'm an NFL Network if
I'm an editor there I'm saying maybe the
next Baker may feel the story goes to
somebody else because there is something
going on here that huge accident
friendship that silver does not try to
hide he's very open about it so I guess
there's some certain some transparency
there that allows us to notice these
things and connect these dots it does
create an opportunity a window for
someone to jump on this story and run
with it without bothering to think maybe
there is video that would either confirm
that there was a snub or would debunk
what is being said and the way it played
out yesterday with little pieces that
were inconclusive that gave Richard
Sherman a chance to double down and
triple down before the conclusive video
came out right and he started deleting
tweets and saying oh this is no big deal
why you make it you made it a big deal
you made a big don't backpedal now
because you've been caught with a
falsehood and wanted the attention for
it and was enjoying it when it was a
thing and then you got proven wrong and
then deleted an act like I don't care
I'm not gonna lose any sleep okay
[ __ ] great
and here's when there's a situation like
this because I've been doing this 18
years now our 18th anniversary of the
launch of PFT is coming up November 1
and we get criticized all the time and I
can deal with it I'm so used to it now
it's like sliding into a really hot tub
at some point you just get used to it
and you think hey you know what this
it's a small price to pay for not having
a real job but I think about the ways we
would have been criticized if we had
done this story and we definitely would
have been criticized for not looking at
the video and I tell you another way we
would have been criticized and this is
exactly what happened here there was no
effort to reach out to the Browns there
was no effort to reach out to Baker
Mayfield to get his side of it so when
you know there's video and when you know
there's another human being involved in
this process you need to do that before
you just run with what ultimately ends
up being BS and I know people are saying
all he's doing is pass
along the quotes that were given to him
but don't we hear all the time now
especially in political reporting you
shouldn't just pass along what someone
says if it's wrong there's an obligation
to look into it desperately when it can
be easily confirmed or debunked drive
videos were everywhere Baker Mayfield is
still alive he can be contacted for
comment on whether he snubbed Richard
Sherman and maybe he would elaborate on
your point Chris hey I was ready to hug
the guy and he gave me kind of a look he
gave me the side eye and he kept going
yeah I mean he acted like he was not
there that was the least like personal
handshake out of everybody in the group
with Richard Sherman look he can bet he
doesn't even look at him in the eye just
walks right by it tells you there was
like jealousy and animosity before it
even started he wanted some issue and
that's the problem with the whole thing
anyways I mean yeah I'm disappointed on
Michael silver I mean I like Michael
silver I know him he's great guy but I'm
disappointed in the fact that you know
okay Richard Sherman's been a pretty
controversial guy I mean the fact that
we're just gonna take what he says and
run run with it you know okay that's
questionable one - you know there's
video of the whole thing I mean come on
it's 2019 there's 20 videos of the whole
thing so to not check that out and get a
little bit more of a you know deeper
look into that yeah that's annoying too
and what's more annoying than anything
okay and you want to talk about old
school and respect to the game again
Richard Sherman your team's for know and
you came off the biggest victory and a
dominant victory and we should be
celebrating that damn the 49ers are one
of the best teams in football but
instead one guy took a took all the
attention and made a controversy out of
a lie out of BS and ran with it until he
was totally exposed and then tried to
act like it's no big deal that's just BS
I throw the challenge flag al river run
overturned the rule and you have the BS
meters full sorry and you know what
Baker Mayfield will have his midweek
press conference today in advance of a
game against the Seahawks and I can't
wait to see what he says and and I and
look based upon who knows what he'll say
May
it'll be some sort of a snide comment
maybe just AI but if I was him I'd be
upset you know he's already gonna be the
target for plenty of criticism that is
warranted when criticism comes his way
based upon Falls facts I think about
this Chris the truth came out by one
o'clock Eastern yesterday yeah
there was no revision no update no
removal nothing of the story that was at
the top of the stack on nfl.com until
358 p.m. so for three hours they knew
the truth and they didn't bother to add
an editor's note or otherwise revise
that story and that impression was
allowed to bake in and that's the
problem here there will be people who
will forever think that Baker Mayfield
disrespected and snubbed Richard Sherman
and DeForest Buckner at midfield before
that Monday night game and all that
Baker Mayfield he's a no-good so-and-so
and he's this and he's that and it's all
based upon what ultimately was a
falsehood falsehood and he's not the
first guy to run off and go to his
sideline certainly after they see the
coin toss that's baloney - that's the
fallback that's the hey I've been caught
red-handed with my my hand in the cookie
jar and I'm gonna change the target I'm
gonna move the goalposts and say well I
was upset because he ran away after the
coin toss that's not what you said
that's not what you said you're right
and he's not the first guy I've seen
guys do that all the time throughout the
NFL on a weekly basis and that's it's
very sensitive of Richard Sherman and
divorce bunker Buckner to want a second
one I mean oh gosh you needed a second
handshake I mean who cares no no that's
that's covered that's cover yeah that's
that's all be I don't even give that any
credence and look at what's on the
screen now the quote from Richard
Sherman they are making way too big of a
story of a blog you made this story out
of this nobody else made a story out of
this you lit the fuse on the bomb that
exploded once Michael Silver published
it at nfl.com it was the story of the
morning everyone was chiming in on how
Baker may feel disrespected the game and
then
the truth started to emerge right hey
he's the one who tried to make a big
story of something that was founded on
something that just didn't happen it
really like you know we seen a lot of
crazy stuff over the years I can't think
of one like this where it's ridiculous
but it's also compelling and fascinating
because I guess Richard Sherman thought
he was gonna get away with it yeah yeah
yeah I guess so but he didn't and now he
looks like a fool and he's a BS and I
don't I can't I can't take him at his
word anymore that's over all right all
right wait we gotta go we probably
gotten ourselves in plenty of trouble
for the figs but you know what I stand
by everything we said I don't think we
crossed any lines you use no profanity I
encourage you to use no profanity I
think we're safe
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports